More than 20 years ago, Ron Haskins and
Isabel Sawhill at the Brookings
Institution sifted the social science
data and found that anyone who finishes
high school, works full-time, and marries
before having children almost never
experiences poverty. They called this the
"success sequence". What the sequence misses
is that each of these steps is enormously complex. It takes a lot of parental
attention, energy, and love before a child
crosses the stage at a high school
graduation. Social networks are critical
to finding a full-time job. A happy
marriage is arguably the most complex
challenge of all. Looked at this way, it's
not so much a sequence as a decades-long dialogue between the individual,
their family and friends, and the
community. Education, work, and marriage
are the marks of a successful life as it
unfolds. We owe Haskins and Sawhill a
profound thanks for bringing us the
success sequence. The job now is
developing the strategies for
strengthening families and communities
so that more people find the path and
stay on it.
What do you think are the
most important factors in success, and
how can we work together to make the
promise of America a reality for more
people? Let us know in your comments. Also,
let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and
be sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.